times sure have changed this early
masterpiece of automotive history
invented in 1769 was powered with Steve
and this 1954 mercedes-benz w196
streamliner was driven by Formula One
race driver Juan Manuel Fangio but
despite its name it's not nearly as
streamlined as the winning car driven by
Lewis Hamilton or this formula one
prototype co-designed by Sebastian
Vettel
fast cars with loads of power under the
hood that's the order of the day here at
the 47th Essen Motor Show it's we're
tuning experts meet to present all the
latest trends and the fans are here in
force there's no shortage of celebrities
either
the 1000 square meter Mercedes fan whirl
display is another highlight the new
Mercedes AMG GT is also making its
german trade show premiere it's only the
second sports car developed entirely
in-house by mercedes AMG one distinctive
feature is the long hood and those who
don't want an off-the-rack sports car
don't come up short either tuning
experts from around the world are here
with tips and ideas
the moment tuning experts when shroud
says body kits are big right now in
Japan and the u.s. they were a hit in
the 80s and 90s but now they're bigger
and badder than ever there are laminate
kits and bolt-on kits where you can
still see the nuts and screws boat on
body kits boat on heist of cachaca Sigma
delicious you need notice Albin wider
fenders a rear spoiler side skirts and
diffuser help make skoda fabia r5 an
aerodynamic standa the concept car gives
a taste of what Fabia has in store for
the 2015 rally season BMW is also
showing up there ConnectedDrive
smartphone app the remote services
feature allows drivers to control their
cars from their phone when it's too hot
in the summer or too cold in the winter
you can switch on your climate control
unit even before you get in the car
and BMW also presented its m performance
accessories the expanded line also
includes sporty retrofitting components
like 21 inch wheels and carbon fiber
accessories for the BMW x4 as well as
front lips and rear diffusers for the m4
all for that customized look II mobility
is also a big theme at the Essen Motor
Show the electric Tesla Model S features
a driving range of up to 500 kilometers
ford was also on hand with another
highlight the unveiling of the new
Mustang in its german premiere the 50th
anniversary edition of the iconic sports
car will be available for direct
purchase in Europe for the first time
ever the new pony car will be available
in Germany and a choice of two engine
configurations
these futuristic tires won't go for sale
anytime soon though but that's what
makes essence special ideas and
inspiration for the cars of tomorrow